[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
hey i'm katie and i'm the producer on
this recipe and i thought it would be
cool today if i showed you how we do our
stop-motion kind of magic moments where
things pop in for the pie section when
i'm putting on the pie hearts the
camera's running the entire time and i
bring in
my pie top and then i bring my hands out
of screen so to make sure they clear the
screen the other thing that's really
important is not to tap the pan or any
of the other items on it everything else
needs to stay so still so that really
the only action is the thing you are
placing in the shot so that's just
popping in and then when i've got them
all on there i cut out the frames
between the last one i put in and then
after i've set down the next one so it
looks something like this that's what i
do if you guys have some cool stop
motion tips you have put them in the
comments or tips on this recipe
thanks bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you